all right first step see how the diagram
they've given you it's kind of like
you know it's got extra bit it's got a
towery sort of stuff the important part
of it is just the triangle
so let's draw a triangle which shows
that information okay let's do that
quickly
yeah in your book there's not really
enough room on the sheet
so you've got a triangle looks roughly
like that i've taken away all the other
extra stuff
you've got the angle in the corner 63
degrees
and there is a right angle um the
diagram doesn't really show
oh it's kind of got that little corner
yeah it's sneaky because it looks like
it's part of the tower
yeah so we've got the right angle here
because the tower is just going straight
up it's not the leaning tower
pisa okay it's measured from
35 meters away from the base which is
why you've got this length here
hold on
now what's the question it says this is
the last sentence in the question right
find the height of the tower okay now in
our diagram
we can put down some information that
says what we're after
find the height
correct to one decimal place okay so
that's what i want
okay now we learnt
about these trig ratios right which were
about the
relationship between two signs of a
triangle and one of the angles
okay what were the three relationships
do you remember what they were the three
ratios
yes soccer tower
okay so the actual ratios are the s and
the c
and the t which stand for
sine sine cos or cosine
right and tan right so we added
all these other letters for what what
were they about
okay they told us which sides are which
right so this one right is
opposite on hypotenuse right you can
fill out now this is going to be
adjacent on hypotenuse and lastly
opposite on adjacency good and of course
the order really matters right that's
why it's yeah
so now you have a look and you say well
your triangle
which of these two sides match up to
what you've got
here's your angle you're looking across
to the height
so that's the that's the opposite side
and then you've got this 35 meters right
next to you right next to you which
makes it adjacent
okay opposite adjacent so as you said
it's tan
right so i'm going to write a sentence
now tan of
the angle right 63 degrees
that's equal to opposite on adjacent
yeah opposite or adjacent i don't know
what the height is
um i don't know yet anyway so let's
write height divided by
adjacent 35 good okay so now i just
rearrange this a little bit because i
want the height
right the height is equal to if i
multiply both sides by
35 that will get rid of the fraction
yeah
35 times
10 63 okay
so there we go i've done all of the bits
that i need with my brain now i reach
from the calculator
okay so this this side cause tan
business right
they apply to different angles in the
triangle
okay so when we stood at when we stood
at this angle the 63 degrees that's why
we said that's opposite to me
and that's why i said this is adjacent
to me so that's why i stick that angle
in there
that's good to apologize good question
right that's probably enough time
people punch into their calculators what
do we get give me a few decimal places
sixty eight point six nine one three six
three six okay now dot it up now i
always like to write down
what the calculator tells me before i
round off
okay because for me sometimes if i go
straight there i'll get it wrong and
then i won't know whether i got
like whether i made an error or not
because my calculator will get wiped off
doing some other questions later on okay
so now i need to round to one decimal
place
it's this one the six does it go up to
seven or does it stay as a six
why does it go up it's because of the
next number which is clearly higher than
you know so it's closer it's closer to
seven
right what units are we in centimeters
kilometers
meters meters to one
decimal place that wasn't so hard